les agriculteurs n'en peuvent plus les
dépôts sauvages se multiplient dans les
champs et les chemins communaux
rassemblées dans divers points d'île de
france vendredi 25 septembre et zions
déverser les déchets qu'ils découvrent
au quotidien play déchetteries sont
payantes pour les artisans et les
horaires d'ouverture sont enfin voila
c'est un peu compliqué quand sa ferme à
15h ou que sais tu pas ouvert tous les
jours des gens plutôt que de les emmener
en déchetterie de s'emmerder
il est temps mais nous les dépose là où
il ya de la place pour des doux et donc
dans nos champs ou dans les chemins
communaux et notamment il ya des fois où
il ya des communes qui demandent à ce
que ça soit carrément les paysans qui
disent enlève alors que c'est sur des
endroits communaux face à ce phénomène
élus autorités et associations de
protection de l'environnement se sont
d'ailleurs réunis la même journée pour
trouver des solutions il faut évidemment
continuer à faire des actions
pédagogiques des actions de prévention
dès le plus jeune âge mais qu'au delà
est d'allier des sanctions effectives
aussi qu'ils puissent être mises en
place
donc l'idée c'est de se confronter
aujourd'hui de faire échanger ensemble
tous ceux qui concourent à notre
territoire à la vie du territoire pour
voir ce qui mériterait d'être amélioré
pour le moment les personnes qui
déversent leurs déchets peuvent recevoir
des amendes
bruno myle yens le député des yvelines
veut aller encore plus loin il faut
effectivement mettre des mesures encore
plus coercitives
là on va jusqu'à la saisie du véhicule
qui me paraît être
importantes comme mesure parce que
souvent la simple amende ne suffit pas
où les gens m'ont par les moyens de la
payer
autre élément évoqué la création d'une
véritable filière de recyclage des
déchets du bâtiment
l'idée serait que les artisans puissent
déposer leurs déchets dans des endroits
dédiés gratuitement